imagine no possessions I wonder if you
can what would a world without money
look like would society be better off
would it eliminate greed or hunger would
we be happier how would you get the
things you need this is what if and
here's what would happen if we had no
money dollars cents savings debt like it
or not this is our society today but it
wasn't always that way several thousand
years ago we were a species of hunters
and gatherers tracking foraging keeping
only what we could carry but along the
way we started experimenting with
agriculture and learned how to grow our
own food we stopped moving and settled
down forming organized communities life
got easier but we still wanted more than
we had so we began to barter
fast-forward a few thousand years to the
first minted coin in 600 BC
cash became king and today money still
does the talking so what would you say
if the world suddenly went broke
understandably it isn't easy to imagine
a world without money so we went ahead
and did the hard work for you one thing
is certain looting and crime would
skyrocket humans have needs we get
hungry we get cold we get jealous law
and economy normally keep these drives
in check determining what we can afford
and what we can get away with but
suddenly everything has lost its value
and whoever's job it is to watch the
goods or maintain order no longer has an
incentive to do so
no one wants to work for free without
paychecks we lose important services no
police no fire department no doctors no
military and what about technology power
isn't free
neither is running water definitely not
gasoline and ditto for cell service and
the internet so our world would be
thrown into a dark anarchic chaos in
this survival of the fittest scenario
gun owners would fare the best and it
would be in their best interest to band
together to claim a greater share of
resources at lower risk with humans
forming into factions we can already
begin to see a repetition of early
seventh airy societies the streets would
no longer be safe you'd have a high
chance of being ambushed and anything
worth taking would likely already be
under armed watch so humans would
establish stationary communities in
fortified positions they may send teams
out to raid nearby communities or
established partnerships with neighbors
we'd have to re-establish the barter
system only it's harder to do in modern
society early civilization had fewer
commodities making fair trade easier but
since we're used to so many different
goods and services it might be difficult
to establish a proper exchange rate it's
not simply a matter of trading apples
for oranges is a Granny Smith worth as
much as a blood orange what if your
apples organic and the orange is GMO
what protections would we have against
counterfeit goods and how can just save
for the future if everything in the
market has a shelf life these are only
some of the concerns that we've more or
less resolved since the introduction of
currency but maybe a world without
currency would be an opportunity to
restructure our society
today we produce enough food to feed
everyone yet people still go hungry and
there's enough shelter for all of us to
sleep soundly yet some of us are
homeless without money we might learn to
be comfortable with less without
fortunes there'd be fewer less
fortunates we might enjoy working freely
for a greater good of course a better
world doesn't have to be a what-if
scenario through trade we've learned to
cooperate and when hard work pays off
were encouraged to innovate the
challenge then is to improve upon the
existing system and empower more people
within it do you think we can do it
where should we start a penny for your
thoughts and pay it forward
you